we got to pull up this project veritas
story
ladies and gentlemen project veritas we
promised we promised it has dropped a
crazy story the latest fda official
blow dart african americans with covet
vaccine is quote where we're going just
shoot everyone calls for a nazi germany
style registry of unvaccinated americans
quote think about it like the jewish
star what
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait but tim
you're you're not saying that right no
i'm reading a headline no that's that's
taylor lee fda economist
the fda economist
said
that
yes yes veritas reports they released a
second video of its coveted vaccine
investigation
and uh a u.s food and drug
administration economist taylor lee who
was recorded calling for forced coveted
vaccinations and a registry for all of
unvaccinated americans
lee said that u.s government policy
would emulate nazi germany when it comes
to the covet vaccine saying quote census
goes door to door if you don't respond
so we have the infrastructure to do it
forced covered vaccinations i mean it'll
cost a ton of money but i think at that
point i think there needs to be a
registry of people who aren't vaccinated
although that's sounding very much like
nazi germany he said
and so
let me make sure i'm being clear
his exact quote is so we have the
infrastructure to do it i mean it'll
cost a ton of money and veritas has
inserted the context of the greater
conversation in their quotes he says
that's although that's sounding very
very germany lee said
nazi germany i mean think about it like
the jewish star for unvaccinated
americans he said so just to be clear
cuz i want to be make sure we you know
cross all the t's and dot all our
lowercase j's he said
although that's sounding very germany
nazi germany and then veritas includes
the context so you understand in that
quote he says so if you put every
anti-vaxxer like sheep into like texas
and you closed off texas from the rest
of the world and you go okay you be you
in texas until we deal with this
pandemic
lee said that due to a large portion of
african-american of the african-american
community being hesitant to take the
coveted vaccine the solution should be
to quote unquote a blow dart on them
wow what
yeah i'm going to be i'm going to be
very very careful about uh how i read
this but here's a quote it says
i think that a lot of the time so
there's also this issue of i remember
reading about how the covid trials they
were having an issue recruiting
african-american people it was because
of a different medication the government
tried to do that was specifically
designed to kill african-americans oh
like a mistrust thing yeah but this
coveted vaccine is safe though
we uh we know that now but like again i
think there is still this big mistrust
and it's like deep rooted the journalist
says yeah i can't blame them lee says i
can't but at the same time like blow
dart that's where we're going
this so so hold on i'm watching it right
now uh james just texted it to me so i'm
watching here on this we always we
always want to be i want to make sure
everything we're doing is reasonable and
within context and that's why i'm you
know talking about what's being said uh
it's one guy it's an fda economist an
economist is not somebody who's going to
be showing up and and instituting policy
on the census
however as much as that would be the
immediate reaction from mainstream media
saying an fda economist is just opining
on his personal rights
i say wow the internal culture of the
fda is psychotic exactly and so if if
this is the access we're getting we're
getting we are getting a glimpse
imagine it this way there's a big
building
big old building full of hundreds of
people
and in the second floor on the top are
all the administrators and all the big
wigs
and everyone in there is hanging out
talking they share a culture in the
workplace
and you look through the keyhole and see
a man say these things
you're like what are they doing in that
building yes i understand this guy is
not an administrator who's going to go
around set policy they actually um they
they clink glasses
i'm watching it now they actually
they clink
they clink acid glasses there i don't
know if it's running or water or
whatever i will say i don't think
it's not gonna happen yeah there's not
gonna be door-to-door maybe a registry
like maybe
um people who aren't vaccinated will be
tracked because we're at that point now
where they're already doing vax mandates
in a bunch of the big cities but i
really do think the united states the
republic will completely collapse before
it gets to that point let me ask this
question um to people out there do you
want government bureaucrats talking
about you like this
talking like government bureaucrats
should never be talking like this about
the american people talking like they
are drunk with power right whether
whether it's behind closed doors whether
it's at a restaurant wherever this is
right this that's the issue here and our
question is it seems like that's what
their attitude is and he's telling us
that's what his attitude is he's someone
that is behind those closed doors this
is obviously a private conversation and
so the question is and i've gone to this
with people who are vaccine hesitant
and
it's you know you talk to them and it's
not like they're there
there's nothing wrong with them there's
nothing different about them in fact
they're saying the same things that joe
biden and kamala a lot of the mainstream
media was saying throughout 2020 they
say oh rory you know there's you can go
to msnbc
joy reid yeah here's an interesting
thing all of it joy reid had responded
that saying at the time i didn't trust
the cdc under donald trump now i'm okay
with it and my response to her is ah yes
exactly what you said but for trump
supporters that under the trump cdc they
were they were okay with it and now
under biden they don't trust it that's
the exact same thing you just said yep
right but it's okay when she says it
because she's joy reid right and so the
issue becomes you know and this is
something i've said to people that like
like my position is check with your
doctor everyone should have the freedom
to choose just i'm literally approach
always on this but um i'm also not
vaccinated because i have natural
immunity because i had like the real
covet i had like the knock you on your
butt like you know couldn't really it
wasn't really on twitter for a while um
i was just you in your chest and your
lungs um
a little bit in my chest i mean i woke
up the one morning had shakes like
legitimate shakes and i was looking at
my i took my temperature and it was low
super low
and
uh then i just threw on a bunch of like
sweat like two layers of sweatpants two
layers of sweatshirts got back under the
covers and then and then my temperature
shot up yeah and went down and it was
crazy and then so that was the first day
there's the pretty much the only day i
had that level of temperature but
you know i just kind of hung out and
they eat like like vietnamese foe and
it's incredible i'm not a fan of heavy
sweat i love it i love the phone oh
fall's great i love the fog i want to
make something love the [ __ ] i'm you're
free to make it oh it's so good it's so
good
in my castle we do not ban that's right
there's no put it i'll put it this way
i'll put it this way yeah it comes with
the cilantro dude yes oh this lunch
right right yeah um egg rolls i'm a good
leader so i am making sure that my share
of the cilantro goes out to all
thank
let them eat cilantro
so yeah i'm like like it wasn't the flu
but it was like not fun i wouldn't want
to do it again so i have natural meaning
we've had a bunch of people on who and
this is really amazing because like even
alex mentioned how like kovid was scary
like you wake up one day and all of a
sudden you're like you're out of breath
constantly and you can't breathe i was
fatigued more than anything else i was
honestly that's what it was it was
tired you know i i had a realization i
tweeted this
i'm looking at what's going on in
australia where you've got the guys just
peppers pepper balling and it's fascism
that's that's i think over words
and i realized something though
i'm rich
i don't got to follow the rules i saw
the met gala and the emmys what do i got
to worry about
we're good we're good yeah it's all
those people that are your favorite if
you're in a certain income bracket then
the rules don't apply to you oh yeah
that's how it works absolutely i get it
i've got i've got the you know tanya
where it says our accounting off the
table yeah yeah yeah
so i was watching and i'm like these
people they're being attacked this is
horrifying and i went wait a minute and
then i looked over at a picture of aoc
and i was like
i'm rich i don't got to worry about any
of that so all i got to do is make sure
i show my bank account to biden
obviously right of course and then they
give you your official you're rich and
you get out of it so this is the reason
i made this i'm making a joke obviously
is that the people who are advocating
for these policies where they will be
beaten by police and pepper spread on
the ground are not rich people the
people like aoc the political elites and
the ultra wealthy are going to these
events they are not being bothered with
but the peasants carry her dress for her
while they wear a mask just the peasants
and i i actually love that i think it's
vogue they did that like mini doc and
you can see the peasants are all they're
carrying the dress and they're all
masked right and it reminds me of and it
pains me to say this but actually i
think the uh uh you know when you talk
about all of all the dystopias out there
which one are we closest to and i think
it actually is suzanne collins yeah but
the hunger games right so
in hunger games remember remember all
the servants in the so the capital is
the elites and everyone else is in the
out in the districts right and then they
they send your kids to go off and die in
afghanistan excuse me i mean in the
hunger games right and um
and then and you watch it on tv and
people can root for various sides and
then and the elites say oh more of that
please yes and and they have all their
crazy hairdos and crazy dresses but
for all they call them the avoxes in in
hunger games and they all have their
tongues cut out the servants the
servants wow and when i was looking at
when i was looking at the mask so avoc
no voice right and so when i was looking
at the all the servants surrounding aoc
with with the masks on i just thought
man they can't speak they can't speak
yeah
suzanne collins i gotta say she nailed
it yeah but i gotta be honest it's um i
think it's a brave new fahrenheit 1984
for vendetta exactly so uh luke uh
rokowski has that shirt is that sure
yeah i seen it it's like you are here
but i'm like i think he's missing one i
think it's only he's only got three
because you think about it's like you
got 1984 you got big brother censorship
spying surveillance you got brave new
world video games
instagram this dopamine you know
antidepressants you got fahrenheit 451
where they're banning all this different
stuff which is still very similar to uh
1984 but in fahrenheit 451 it was people
demanding the censorship because they
were offended by everything and then you
got v for vendetta you know viva
vendetta was in the movie at least
the virus happened right the virus yeah
locked everybody down what was the 19
zone what was the name of the party yeah
yeah oh the party um i don't what was
the party's name i can't think of it do
they have a name i don't i'm not sure
they did
like the new guardian or the new
government had a name or something i
forgot exactly but it was the st mary's
virus i think that's right yeah yeah
young me park was saying north korea is
the hunger games right now the cities so
is it seoul it's the capital of north
korea no pyongyang
south korea pyongyang is like the
capital right and everyone else is like
well eating human corpses i mean it's
like
no electricity right just
massive yes north korea and people get
brought to the capitol north korea
experienced an extreme
famine
in the 1990s
and so now what's going on
generationally is the famine generation
in north korea
is attaining adulthood so they are
coming up and because they are so
stunted that their children are having
issues as well but also you also had a
population drop at that time because of
the starvation and so now that's leading
to a second famine underneath all of
this as well as just the insane policies
of that country they're going to
collapse
i was uh when i saw the met gala in the
emmys i'm like these are literally
hunger games villains it's crazy this is
the capital right i mean how can you not
how good it's it's you know i i wish
there was some higher literature we
compared to but it really is hunger
games yeah no it's it's a good point i
mean they they uh they're all dressed
like you know crazy but here's here's
here's the thing about the hunger games
that i wonder if who's it suzanne
collins she's in college yeah did she
know about behavioral sync
i'm done calling it wokeness i'm calling
it behavioral sync from now yeah
i mean think about it yeah you're
familiar with behavioral sync in the
right the right utopia experiments how
go
uh confined space unlimited food and and
water and the rats basically went insane
oh yeah yeah yeah yes i didn't really
know that term yeah but one of the
things uh is the beautiful ones one of
the things uh that emerged from it was
what the researcher called the beautiful
ones who would just groom themselves
just not constantly trying to poop up
their hair and be like looking really
pretty while doing nothing else get a
selfie and that's what i see as the met
gala they look ridiculous like plastic
robot people and i'm like these are the
beautiful ones
in their world of abundance with no
responsibility and instant gratification
they are those who are just sitting
there grooming each other then you get
the violence in the streets and those
are the crazy violent ones eric hoffer
in um in true believer
the great longshoreman philosopher had
this line back in the 1950s where he
said
um mass movements don't usually arise
among the working class because they are
working right mass movements generally
arise among the affluent and boards
yep you got nothing else to do man no
purpose no direction well and also
because without having that without he
was essentially saying there is there's
something to the human psyche where in
human nature whereby in you to go
through a meaningful rite of passage
from adolescence into adulthood usually
that's that's work that's usually
through work through rigor through
taking the taking on of responsibility
uh the is sort of the mantle of
adulthood however when you you have a
certain level of
affluence when you have a certain level
of abundance that never happens and so
you're now missing something in your
psyche that you're constantly searching
for and so that these people will create
these mass movements in order to fulfill
that internal need that they have thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you